翻訳: Toshiro Suzuki
校正: Koichiro YODA
（音楽開始）
（拍手）
（音楽終了）
えー
ありがとうございます
彼が「たくや超人」
私が「勇登BEATS」
２人合わせて「超人ビーツ。」と言います
どうぞよろしくお願いいたします
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
それでは僕も少しだけですが
お話しさせていただきます
ええとですね
本当に今 日本ではですね
昨今ダンスブームで
本当に日本中ダンサー人口って
すごく増えているんですよ
その中で僕たち超人ビーツ。は
ちょっと変わったチームとして
活動させていただいております
何が変わっているのかというとですね
僕たちは「面白そうなことは
全部取り入れる」と
そういうモットーの元に活動している
チームでございます
たとえば「ジャグリング」
たとえば「ヒューマンビートボックス」
たとえば「マジック」や「パントマイム」
何でも面白そうやと思ったものはですね
全部取り入れて
ダンスと混ぜてみたりとか
もしくはそのダンサーならではの解釈で
再構築して新しいショーを作って
そのオリジナルのショーを作って
演技をさせていただいております
もちろん うまくいかないときもありまして
様々な試行錯誤 トライアンドエラーの中で
いろんなものを作ってます
具体的な例を言うとですね
たとえば「皿回し」って
みなさんご存知やと思うんですけども
皿回しが「めっちゃ面白いんちゃうか？」
って思った時期がありまして
皿を買いまして ものすごい練習をして
皿を回せるようになったんですよ！
僕ら二人とも
で ちょっと前に
ダンスと混ぜてみようと思って
めっちゃ練習したんですけど
まあ 一切混ざらなかったという
（笑）
そういうこともございました
でも そんな失敗とかの中で
試行錯誤の中で
結構 本当に誰も見たことがないような
新しいものが生まれたりとかして
そんな感じでパフォーマンス活動を
続けております
本当に最初に言った通り
日本ってすごいダンサー人口も多いし
ダンスのスキルも世界的に見ても
すごい高いんですよ
その中で「僕たちがステージに立つ
意味っていうのは何かな？」
っていうのをちょっと考えた時にですね
僕ら二人でしか出来ないもの
そういったものをですね
みなさんにご提供というか
ご披露させていただける
そんな存在になれればいいなと思って
活動を続けております
「超人ビーツ。」っていうのは
ダンスチームの名前ではあるんですけども
それだけではなくて
僕は「新しいダンスのジャンル」やと思って
活動させてもらってます
「ダンスをベースにとにかく面白そうなもの
っていうのを混ぜて作った
全く新しいパフォーマンス」
これが超人ビーツ。だと思っています
今日はみなさまに短いショーですけども
あと２つだけ演目を
ご披露させていただきます
１つはダンスとジャグリングを融合した
ちょっと面白いものと面白いものを
掛け合わせて作った
オリジナルのパフォーマンス
そして １つは 逆にそういった
ギミックを全て取っ払って
ストリートダンス自体の面白さっていうのを
フィーチャーした作品
これを２つ続けてご披露したいと思います
みなさんに楽しんでいただくために
作ったショーなので
ぜひ拍手とか 盛り上がり
どうぞよろしくお願いいたします
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
それではたくや超人
準備よろしいでしょうか
（ヒューマンビートボックス）
参りましょう！
（ヒューマンビートボックス開始）
（トランペットの音色）
（ビートリズム音）
（ヒューマンビートボックス終了）
（英語）準備はいいかい？
（ヒューマンビートボックス開始）
（拍手）
（ヒューマンビートボックス終了）
（音楽開始）
（拍手）
（音楽終了）